[Musique]
c'est un véritable phénomène qui divise
les français alors que le gouvernement a
imposé depuis le 16 mars dernier un
confinement général le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que certains ne le
respecte pas à la lettre
c'est la raison pour laquelle de
nombreux français décrochent chaque jour
leur téléphone pour dénoncer à la police
leur voisin où les quidams qui ne
respectent pas scrupuleusement les
consignes du chef de l'état ainsi les
appels au 17 ont été multipliés par deux
ou trois selon les régions en grande
partie en raison de ces dénonciations si
le ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner n'encourage pas ce qu'il décrit
comme une société de délation le chef du
service d'information et de la
communication de la police nationale
michel lavaud est plus nuancé je
n'utiliserais pas le terme de délation
le confinement obéit à des règles
il n'est pas anormal qu'on nous appelle
pour nous dire que certains ne
respectent pas le confinement certains
vont même plus loin selon le parisien
une femme aurait appelé le 17 pour
dénoncer son mari qui ne respectaient
pas le confinement car il aurait quitté
à plusieurs reprises leur domicile pour
aller voir sa maîtresse et vous êtes
vous pour ou contre dénoncé ses voisins
qui ne respectent pas le confinement
alors là j'ai envie d'avoir votre avis
chez vous êtes vous pour ou contre
dénoncé ses voisins qui ne respectent
pas le confinement rené qu'est ce t'en
penses tu che marseille
les paccots pour les balancer un peu
pareils ça maintenant a contrario jouer
le parasite eve et j'espère que t'as pas
trivial les voisins si moi je sais que
j'aille ne savent où des impacts juillet
puisque la normale
là je balance parce que ta vidéo
maintenant pour le reste c'est chez nous
assure girondine
moi je suis d'accord avec rené si
j'entends effectivement de la violence
de la maltraitance évidemment que
j'affectionne ainsi de principe de
précaution mais en revanche pour ça non
ce serait la pire des choses de dénoncer
à la nuit je peux mettre à la fenêtre et
je veux dire et au connard tu fais un
rêve de sortir mais généralement un même
homme je vais pas accabler la police et
j'ai passé en patois salle et avec ça
voilà c'est pas toi selon lui l'époque
c'est plus à la fraternité à l'entr'aide
à la compagne à la compassion que voilà
à dénoncer le voisin saint mathieu et
bien moi j'étais très partagé toute la
journée et aujourd'hui maintenant je dis
oui je dis oui effectivement je suis
désolé mais il ya des moments dans la
vie que ce soit quelqu'un qui garde son
pote d'handicapés voilà est là
aujourd'hui encore plus grave
effectivement il s'agit encore une fois
de mort c'est à dire quand je vous
rappelle que la semaine dernière avec le
beau temps
les gens sont sortis il faut vite
jourdain compassion d'incubation on
parle on parle maintenant du jeudi noir
et la semaine prochaine on va annoncer
un nouveau pic parce que les gens sont
sortis
lorsque un nouveau pic de nouveaux pics
vos enfants vos cousins vos parents qui
risquent de mourir au kg à un moment
donné les gens qui sortent
oui il faut les dénoncer parce qu'il
s'agit de nos vies de vos vies donc si
on veut un jour sortir de ce
déconfinement centre de la crise
économique et revivre
il faut que les gens se tient à carreau
il le pont pas alors je suis désolé il
est des moments où dans la vie il faut
savoir dénoncer c'est un geste civique
mais jean michel mathieu
tu sais je t'aime entre dénoncé tu peux
aller toquer à leur porteur désolé je
vous ai vus sortir thaler et sur les
tout seul solidaires et selon samira
rien bien sûr que si parce qu'il ya
quand même quelque chose de cynique ont
des noms des mattei en disant que le
tabac n'est pas avec tp on pas des
commerces qui sont si j'étais encore au
vert et là comme par hasard les seules
fois où dans l'administration on peut
dénoncer c'est pour les impôts ou lattes
et rémunérés quand tu balances quelqu'un
qui paie pas ses impôts il ya quand même
quelque chose d'un peu cynique et là
franchement le corona et si on est
solidaires nous chez les likoud et pas
de balancer les autres c'est pour sauver
alors bis la jambe c'est bon je vais
vous montrer une image la dénonciation
de ses voisins qui ne respecteraient pas
le confinement est revenue qu'elle donc
quelque chose de plus en plus courant
voulais vous montrer le témoignage d'une
femme qui a justement été dénoncés
s'étant belgique et ça se passe
exactement de la même manière en france
regardez vers minuit minuit et demi
entre eux en a entre les deux n'est venu
toquer à la porte et la police
[Musique]
assise dans son salon
approché un peu la flemme j'en appelle
soit six au bord la native de brion n'a
pas constaté
et puis je sens une personne ils sont
rentrés dans le salon d'office je me dis
que ben voilà il ya que moi et mon
compagnon est mon ami qui loge là mais
qui de chez moi depuis avant le
confinement et que c'est une
c'est une question de santé jeudi
rentrée mais psychologique pour lui de
ne pas être seul chez lui elle me répond
tout de suite c'est la loi il n'a pas
essayé vous le confinement c'est le
confinement
c'est un procès de 150 euros mais sur un
ton vraiment exécrable et sans que j'aie
le temps de grandir plus d'expliquer la
situation en fait apparemment ils
verbalisent chaque personne domiciliée
sur le toit voilà c'est mille euros que
je ne pourrais pas payé et que je ne
préfère pas j'attendrai passer au
tribunal a clairement j'en dors pas je
pensais pas que j'en serai marqué comme
ça mais oui clairement sa marque
voilà alors c'est une histoire de fou
hein alors mathieu ou vous comprenez que
les gens au dénonce mme giraldi de
voulait réagir encore là mais évidemment
mathieu était et est bien mignon
évidemment j'entends ce que tu dis qu'on
est tous évidemment concerné on veut
absolument sa part est et dans les
meilleures conditions et complète tous
touchés mais pour autant c'est quoi tes
critères toi matthieu delormeau pour
dénoncer en fait tu vas faire quoi
mais derrière la ford fait mettre à la
fenêtre va prendre un chrono derrière
ton sud a fait hier mais vous sortez
pourquoi être qu'ils avaient une bonne
raison
tu vas d'acter les critères c'est
impraticable en fait pour maintenant je
fait j'ai un guide éventuellement
instauré géraldine moi je dis pas que je
dis pas que ce sera ce sera fait de
manière facile
je dis juste qu'il a abandonnée par dont
il faut le dire en france les français
on est comme ça on est latin on ne ne
comprend que la caresse et la claque la
caresse et la claque est là on peut m'en
pardon mais me dire qu'on est tous
confinés qu'on ne confère un travail
physique touche chez nous et qu'on va
encore être décalé le président va
parler mais encore nous décaler parce
qu'il ya des gens qui n'ont rien à
[ __ ] qui ne respectent rien ni les
malades ni les morts ni nos personnes
âgées et que nous on paye pour ces gens
là il ya un moment c'est non alors je
suis désolé géraldine encore une fois je
leur dis je le redis je suis pour ça
tout comme je suis pour aussi pardon et
jeux de lui quand je vois des gens des
salles où il n'y a pas d'autre mot se
garer sur une place handicapée pardon ça
ça se dénoncer des choses dans la vie où
parfois ses civic voilà rené rené
mathieu oui je te colle
et pas de venir habiter à marseille
parce que j'efface en tout ca la fidh
basée à marseille quoi moi que tu
souhaites tu sortiras pas tranquille je
te le dis je suis sauvé la vie de ta
femme en se balançant si je sais ce
n'est pas parce que mais qu'il est dans
la rue il va tuer ma femme ilva mais là
on s'est lâché tu me pas là je me balade
mais ses nombreuses journées c'est une
image exemplaire
si les gens malades ou pas alors moi ce
que je veux dire par là rené écoute moi
ça qu'est-ce qui les gens justement ont
peur d'être balancé que du coup ils ne
sortent plus c'est comme ça qu'est la
maladie que le virus va partir et je dis
que c'est une image c'est justement en
faisant ça bien sûr comme ça qu'on va
sauver des gens et peut-être quelqu'un
de ta famille renée donc penser un petit
peu un peu moins à toi peut-être que moi
je parle c'est que quand même voilà nous
séduit quelque part dieu des modèles la
paix ou camille de doigts mais rené j'ai
pas dit j'étais mieux lorsque les droits
l'algue est abandonnée dans le mini koné
dramane délatté en italie du sud tous
aller la paix dans le nord de l'italie
et l'espagne restent très bien le
confinement des habitants du pays je
voudrais g roupe les trois pays les plus
touchés c'est l'italie l'espagne la
france n'est pas contre les exemples les
pays latins mais alors s'il vous plaît
simulation très gentiment mathieu 6,6
alors géraldine mais il ya des gens qui
les gens qui dénoncent leurs voisins et
envoie des lettres de délation à la
mairie au commissariat de police ou à la
gendarmerie
voilà une à plein et le maire de petit
baby en seine-maritime expliquait
justement comment ça se passait chez eux
regarder il ya beaucoup de dénonciation
depuis maintenant une semaine 1 reçoit
régulièrement que ce soit en appel
téléphonique à la mairie ou ou des
messages sur les réseaux sociaux que ce
soit sur mon compte ou ou le compte de
la ville le compte facebook notamment
d'habitants qui nous font savoir que à
tel ou tel endroit il ya des gens qui
sont dehors qui sortent et que c'est pas
normal
jean-michel oui et puis en plus ce match
tu dis des conneries parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui peuvent sortir ont
déjà été contaminées et sont guéris donc
il risque plus de transmettre autre fac
tu vas te dénoncer les gens qui sont
plus qu'ils peuvent plus
la maladie mais aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'ils en salsa que personne aujourd'hui
ne sait s'il est malade ou pas même toi
tu n'as pas tout mais ce match je n'ai
pas testé et mathieu essaie d'avoir le
cul propre
si toi tu faisais un dieu du bruit de la
nuit parce qu'il fait une fête qui les
voit that eux dénoncent dirai bravo le
voisin alors de chocolat la lave et
david jean michel jean michel lalle à la
coupe là franchement la comparaison
n'est pas du tout la même
la balade à poney on peut ne pas être
d'accord avec mathieu met l'accent sur
la relation
oui mais la comparaison n'a rien à voir
là vraiment rien à voir rien voir j'ai
des ratures attendez une seconde de m
oui malcuit contre tout les délations
sur tout pas déranger les gens qui
paient pas leur savent qu'ils payent pas
leurs impôts qui payent pas ta je suis
contre toutes les nations
celle là elle est là pour sauver nos
vies nos grands parents n'oubliez pas
parce qu'on a parlé l'autre jour dans
l'émission parle des ehpad
le nombre de personnes de grands parents
qui ont 70 80 ans qui sont seuls dans
leur appartement qui peuvent pas se
faire à bouffer qui sont en train de
crever sur place on découvre des
changements de leur appartement depuis
une semaine par mois
pensez un peu aux autres arrêtés c'est
juste un truc de délation penser aux
autres bordel on a train de mourir il
s'agit de ses cadets venez venez venez
rené bonnet alors moi là où je suis
d'accord
géraldine avec les hôtes du pq sont
toujours restés canalisée par la bndes
qui a [ __ ] l affiche de la voiture de
l'art de qu'il fallait qu'elle parte de
l'immeuble faisant partie était sur une
dernière le tout à tous on a été tous
scandalisés la fille elle a fait le tour
des voix veille à des tpe
mais là c'est pareil tu te prends les
courses relais mais tu vas au bel pays
libre à toi tu rentres chez toi sinon je
t'aime plaindra mais de là et le courage
et de le faire pourquoi tu téléphones
anonymes mal pour que d'autres fassent
le travail que toi que tu dénonces leur
victoria où tu te reposes des affranchis
tu proposes chacun sa justice on va tous
se péter la gueule et puis je vois la
gueule tu vas tu dis oh rentre chez toi
quoi
et qu'est-ce qui a sa part d'ombré sur
la suisse pourrait voir ce qu'on pense
les téléspectateurs s'il vous plaît les
chéris
regardez ce composé faut-il ses voisins
qu'il respecte pas le confine au oui à
48% non à 52 c'est vraiment c'est
presque 50 50 c'est très très partagés
non non non non non non c'est non à 52
points donc c'est pas tout seul sur un
camp mais c'est vraiment à 500 points
contre avait déchiré arrêté au croyez
que ça laisse beaucoup on voit bien que
ça reflète pas ce que vous dites là
puisqu'on à 48 52 et là vous êtes à 75
donc voila merci donc mathieu n'est pas
complètement isolé non plus puisqu'ils à
48 % des gens qui nous regardent qui
votent comme il ya eu énormément de
réactions sur ce sujet